are there any intensive
Retreats that you recommend or extended
Retreats and I suppose the broader
question is how how can one know where
to
practice and vet properly right if
someone wants to do a Meditation Retreat
and the reason I ask is for instance
with psychedelics which are still
largely underground at this point even
though at some point hopefully there
will be an entire framework for
administering them reasonably safely to
people who fit certain
criteria if someone finds a facilitator
says I've never had no one under my care
has ever had a bad trip that is a huge
red flag because it means they're either
diluting themselves they're lying or
they're really inexperienced right those
are kind of the only options on the
table because you're you're effectively
using nuclear power
to change the plasticity of the
mind of course there are going to be
Adverse Events of course they are going
to be outliers and so you want someone
who has actually handled those cases
right if you go to to push my F1 analogy
if you go to a racetrack let's just say
and you're going to a track day and the
track runner says we've never had any
accident of any type on our track that's
a bad thing because someone's going to
have an accident you want to make sure
they have protocols in plays they have
experience they have the presence of
mind to handle it calmly etc etc so I
could see that applying also to vetting
meditation Retreats but putting myself
in the position of someone listening to
this I might say holy of the people
who' have tried meditation once X
percentage have these persistent
problems like this seems really really
dangerous maybe I just shouldn't
meditate so for those people to maybe
offset that a little bit are there
Retreats that you
ever recommend and how can someone vet
if they're considering doing a
retreat I mean I think that a lot of it
has to do with matching the goals to the
person so I don't want to necessarily
rule out or recommend any particular
Retreat across the board yeah I think
that there are certain Retreats that are
pretty repeat offenders mhm and are ones
that have like high dose like 15 hours
of meditation a day no movement practice
mhm often you see an alternation between
walking right and sitting and sometimes
there's even yoga
added so you know more intense practices
with no movement and also not
necessarily tailored feedback from
teachers mhm so I would be very careful
before going on one of those and I think
just in general like there are so many
different options for Retreats these
days you can do like an afternoon
Retreat where it's only a couple hours
like start there TI trade up and you can
do this at home you don't even have to
necessarily spend the money you can just
download an app and do that for a day
and see how you do you know like tit
trate up and and just do it like one
at a day at a time if you're worried
about like you know rather than signing
up for a 10-day Retreat something I have
not mentioned before is that I've done
shorter meditation Retreats like two or
three days with no issues whatsoever
yeah so I just want to point that out
the other fine detail that I want to
mention because I think Spirit Rock runs
a very good ship and I think they're
very well formatted and they do have
safeguards in place that they
explicitly advise against
fasting and I violated that rule I
overrode that right and also added the
psychedelics which certainly I had not
mentioned to anyone until I had already
sort of
capsized yeah so I think those are
definitely things I mean that this this
never used to be an issue but I know
that that people are doing that that
that people are
bringing psychedelics on Retreats and I
think a lot of the
Retreats they have to manage a lot of
people yeah people are already having
like challenging
experiences the regular kind of
challenging
experiences with meditation and so to
have to to manage people who are also
taking psychedelics is that's a lot it's
not really fair to a Meditation Retreat
so I think it's going to be invisible to
them for the most part yeah I'm sure
right it's not going to be Ed just like
people lie on their medical intakes
about the psychiatric medications
they're taking if they are wedded to
taking psychedelics with a facilitator
this happens all the time people sort of
misrepresent their health
status because they're so vested in this
last hail marry Obi-Wan Kenobi or our
final hope solution Panacea that they
see in psychedelics and I have to
imagine that also happens with
meditation Retreats I'd love for you to
say a bit more about repeat offenders
are there any
other characteristics or format issues
that you see producing more problems
than others outside of what you already
mentioned so in terms of the retreat or
meditation type or in terms of personal
risk factors The Retreat or meditation
type that seem to produce a higher
volume of people with these
issues I would say Retreats that recruit
or are attracting a certain type of
meditator which by the way like you fit
the bill like pretty exactly when I
heard this story I was like wow like
that's pretty emblematic of like
textbook yeah young male pretty educated
combining all sorts of of tools you know
fairly aggressive we used to joke that
one of the risk factors was zealotry a
kind of zealotry a zeal so something
like that and so people there's a
certain kind of almost like
military this is going to be a really
really hard Retreat like those types of
Retreats are a little bit more high-risk
and I think there's also the combination
of the person and the teacher/ format
mhm one of the things that we found that
was really shocking in the varieties of
contemplative experience study is that
on one hand we expected to see people
who ran into problem S as people who had
lots of problems in their lives but when
we actually like looked at the data like
75% had graduate degrees MD phds
JDS you know these were like CEOs of
major companies these are like super
high achieving people and we were like
this is so interesting how do we make
sense of that and we're like oh right
being a high achiever is a risk factor I
was just about to say like the drug
addiction in the medical profession is
off the charts like suicides off theart
sharts so right it's because like these
are the kinds of people that you're like
okay you're going to sit and follow your
breath you know and they're like okay
like they're the ones that show up early
for the meditation and they're the last
ones to leave they're the ones that are
like they follow instructions exactly
they would never modify the instructions
for their own benefit that would not
even occur to them unless they make it
more intense and this is kind of where
trauma comes in if you've been trained
to scan what are the expectations here
what are the sort of unspoken social
rules that I need to Ace in order to not
be punished if that's like kind of youro
running in the background then we have
all these people like following
instructions exactly not modifying them
basically listening to an external
Authority rather than their own internal
Compass that's the recipe for disaster
and so if you can interface with you
know really any type of meditation
spiritual system with your having
maintaining your inner
Compass that's going to be a recipe for
a much better outcome but not not
everybody can do that and not all
systems are tolerant of that and so I
would also encourage and we've had lots
of trainings with meditation centers
trying to be able to be able to be more
flexible and so if somebody knows like I
need to be able to leave the meditation
you know in the middle so that I'm not
like continuing to meditate and the
meditation manager Meditation Retreat
manager is like no that won't be allowed
you have to stay if you come you have to
stay for the whole thing that's not
really allowing flexibility so are there
ways that people can titrate the amount
of practice that they're getting within
a retreat is there a way to like hey on
on Wednesday we'll have Burger night for
people who need to like increase the
like
fat intake you know that is actually
happening now yeah the vegetarian diet
piece is super interesting I mean I I
don't know if the sort of Acuity is is
sufficient as a factor but it it makes
me think also with for instance some of
these conditions that are let's just say
contraindicated for most psychedelic use
schizophrenia borderline personality
disorder understanding these are all
kind of like word salad things taken
from the DSM which is kind of a big
question mark for a lot of reasons but
some of these more for lack of better
terms sort of chaotic conditions are
contra indicated respond really well to
something called metabolic Psychiatry
with Chris Palmer has spoken about this
out of Harvard using high fat
effectively ketogenic diet but like high
fat moderate protein some of these
people respond incredibly well so if you
look though at the food served at these
meditation Retreats uniformly
effectively the exact polar opposite
right which is kind of interesting